good morning and welcome to this press
conference today is chemistry day at the
Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences we
have concluded our meeting and we are
ready to announce this year's Nobel
Prize in Chemistry and as usual we'll do
it both in English and in Swedish I'm
Jordan Hansen secretary-general of the
Academy with me on the podium today is
to my right professor
Soros no girl Linzer chairman of the
Nobel Committee for chemistry and on my
left professor who loved Rome strim who
is a member of the committee and an
expert in the field of the prize later
on we hope to have one of our new Nobel
laureates with us on a phone line this
year's Nobel Prize in Chemistry is about
the world's smallest machines
Oris Nobel Prize handler on various
means Tom affinor kavita's cops Academy
nobis looted at ETH ago hundra Saxton
Nobel Prize SME immense until
jean-pierre Sauvage Sir James Frazer
Stoddard oak Bernard L fearing her for
design Oh Cynthia's of molecular Mahina
the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
has decided to award the 2016 Nobel
Prize in Chemistry jointly to Jean
Pierre Subash Sir James Fraser Stoddard
and Bernard L Ferran hub for the design
and synthesis of molecular machines like
atom egoyan seances red desides issue
the tribal pre Nobel - Amy dermal says
rompilla Sauvage Sir James Frazer
Stoddard Eber na L Ferran ha
la Concepcion Ellison test machine
molecular Phil design on synthase
molecular machine supply Keeravani
synthase molecular nick machine here we
have our new nobel laureates with us on
the screen about me and Ron Piazza Bosch
was born in Paris in 1944 he is now
emeritus professor at the University of
Strasbourg and director of research
emeritus at the Santa national de la
beche our scientific CNRS in Strasbourg
in France Sir James Frazer Stoddart was
born in 1942 in Edinburgh in the United
Kingdom he is currently the board of
trustees professor of chemistry at
Northwestern University in Evanston
Illinois United States and burner or Ben
Vereen hub was born in 1951 in barger
campus comb in the Netherlands he is
professor of organic chemistry at the
University of Groningen in the
Netherlands so that's our new Nobel
laureates and now I'd like to give the
word to Professor snow guru please sir
who will provide some introductory
remarks on this year's Nobel Prize in
Chemistry please thank you maybe this
morning you ground your coffee maybe you
use the motorized vehicle to get here
you used man-made machines operating on
the centimeter two meter length scale
it's been the dream of scientists for
over half a century to take this
development all the way down to the
molecular scale that nanometers a
nanometer is 1 million times smaller
than a millimeter in here we have some
molecular machines a molecular motor a
molecular muscle and we're like a memory
an elevator and there's a molecular car
this amazing development is due to
several ingenious chemical innovations a
machine needs moveable parts and a
mechanism to convert energy input to
motion in a defined direction so the
first challenge for the chemists was to
make something that can move this one
you may recognize from yesterday
this one won't do the work it's
beautiful but it needs to be connected
to something one way to make a physical
connection is this somewhat more ugly
but here we have two wings that move
relative to one another but they are
freely joined there is no chemical bond
between them to make this one it's a
piece of cake you can buy it at the
local supermarket this one requires some
very clever chemistry and this year's
laureates have developed new synthetic
strategies to make molecules like this
with good yields the second challenge is
to convert energy input to motion in a
defined direction here the problem is
that molecular systems have a strive to
reach equilibrium and fluctuate around
it in random motions so here the
challenge was to overcome this and the
laureate took advantage of a molecular
property called chirality or a symmetry
so now you may be curious to see what
these machines look like I'm sorry you
can't see them there are more than
thousand times smaller than a human hair
so we need a magnifying lens and I think
my colleague Oleg Armstrong can help
here
thank you for that and thank you Sora
so definitely we need a magnifying lens
so as you heard this award is all about
the world's smallest machines there was
tiniest machines and you can actually
see an example of such a machine in this
little picture this is a microscope
image and you cannot only see it you can
also see it moving as you can see here
and they are really very tiny these
structures only a few nanometers in long
length and as you heard as a comparison
a strand of hair is more than 1,000
times thicker so really the tiniest
possible machine you can experience so
how can you make these machines well as
Sora very cleverly explain to you one
very very important breakthrough in this
area came in 1983 when jean-pierre
Subash and his group made a so-called
molecular chain and the way they did is
it that they constructed a molecular
ring and this is symbolized here in blue
and they had a molecular crescent shaped
a crescent shaped molecule here in red
and you can see the chemical structures
here on the sides and really mix those
two structures together with a small
copper ion the copper ion can act as a
type of glue gluing those two pieces
together in a type of complex like this
and what you then can do is that can you
add a third component another red
component here you can see the structure
over here and then you can stitch them
together chemically and what you then
will get after you remove them the
copper ion is a type of molecular chain
type of structure also known as a
catenin and here you have a type of
mechanical bond where the two rings can
move freely relative each other but
cannot come loose from one another so
it's a type of mechanical bond
what this open entire field of molecular
machinery and it also reinvigorated
another field which is called
topological chemistry but you actually
study very complex situations like this
but jean-pierre Sauvage in his group
also realized at this point was that
here you have what is called
translational isomerism the cause in the
presence or in the absence of metal ion
here you have a large shift in shape in
the structure up to one nanometer change
in shape another very very important
breakthrough in this area came in 1991
when Sean face who stood at in his group
designed a so called molecular shuttle
they used an other type of mechanical
bond which is based on an electron rich
axilla like this in red here and they
also made a ring shaped molecule which
is electron poor and you can see it's
open here on one side and the structures
you can find down here if you mix those
two structures together in a solution
electron rich will be attracted by
electron poor and then you can ring
closed the structure and now you have
formed a type of rucksacks Trotec same
structure where you have the ring can
move freely along the axial but cannot
come loose because of the two large
stoppers at each end here and this is
another type of mechanical bond as you
may understand and here what you can see
also is that you have a shuttle effect
so that this ring can move between two
different stations in this axial on this
actual so you can see it can move like
this after these fundamental discoveries
what these two groups could also show is
that you can actually control this
movement so in 1994 the stolid group
could show by building in as symmetries
in the axial that you can actually
control the movement of the ring between
the two stations and this we can do for
example by electrochemical means in the
same year
group can show similarly that you can
build in a symmetries in the catenate
rings and by electrochemistry you can
also control the movement the rotation
of wandering relative on and another
after these fundamental breakthroughs
both of these groups have done a lot of
work and they have constructed more and
more complex structures and more and
more functional structures you have to
give you a couple of examples out of
very many so wash group have for example
design the molecule constructed a
molecule which which can extend and
contract extend and contract
dramatically in a very controlled manner
and this is exactly this is actually
mimicking the function that we see in
our muscle tissue so we can call it the
type of molecular muscle and the storage
group they have done many things one
example they made was a so called
molecular elevator or lift where you
have a plane in red here that can move
between two stations upon sternal
stimulus external stimulus like so so
one component in a machine that is very
very important is the motor component
and especially maybe the rotary motor
component and in particular a component
that we can rotate only in one direction
and that is a fundamental challenge and
that challenge was met in 1999 by Ben
ferry ha and his group so what they
could do in this particular case was
that they made a molecule they built in
a symmetry in the molecule and they had
to rotor blades as you can see here
connected to what is called an isomer
risible borne a bond that can change and
using this structure they can get
unidirectional directional rotation and
the way this works is that when you
shine light to this molecule the rotor
blade will flip over like so almost 180
degrees there you see and that will
create tension in the molecule as you
can see here that doesn't the molecule
has a light tension it wants to release
the tension
and that happens in a thermal step which
is irreversible
pretty much irreversible and then you
have another pulse of light coming in
you get another flip of the rotor you
create more tension and then in the
final step you have a thermal relaxation
relaxation again and then you're back at
very started and this cyclic moment you
can do over and over again in a very uni
directional rotation manner after this
fundamental breakthrough 1999 the
fahringer group and other groups have
been working continuously on this field
and they have perfected as structures
even more so nowadays they have
structures that can rotate very fast up
to twelve thousand revs per second they
have motors that can rotate in either
direction
they have also they can also change the
direction at will if they want to they
have also worked with there was a show
that you can use these molecular motors
these tiny molecular motors to rotate
much much larger objects as you can see
here here you have a glass rod and this
class Sorensen micrometer size that
means this is ten thousand times larger
than the little molecular motor and as
you can see the motor action can
actually be used to drive the rotation
this very large rod and the final
example I have for this from this group
is a more playful example and what they
wanted to show here is they wanted to
demonstrate that that you can control
the motion of a small machine on a
surface and what they actually did then
was that it they constructed a molecule
where you have an axial type of
structure and in each corner of this
actual they connect a motor component so
what this thing will look like is some
kind of four-wheel drive small molecular
car and the way they imagined is to work
as you can see on this cartoon where you
can see that this charge can move along
the surface in this manner and this
particular machine
or molecule is exactly what you see here
that's what you see the machine moving
around along the surface so what these
three lawyers have shown have done they
have opened this entire field of
molecular machinery and they have
constructed as they're shown that is
indeed possible to make machine or
machine like function at molecular scale
and they have really mastered motion
control at the molecular scale so now I
think you all can say that this is
really fantastic
right but what is it used for
what can it be used for and I would like
to say that this is until now
fundamental science is this basic
fundamental science they have addressed
scientific fundamental fundamental
scientific challenges and shown that is
it indeed possible and you can say
probably you can say that that the
development stage here is similar to
what it was in the beginning of the 19th
century when many scientists
demonstrated different electrical
machines as you can see on some of them
here and of course this electrical
machines from the beginning of the 19th
century they created a revolution and as
you can see we have nowadays we have
electrical machines everywhere so we
think that these small molecular
machines we have seen some tendencies
towards applications but the future will
say it will show what kind of
applications will come out of this so by
that I just want to give the word back
to our secretary-general thank you very
much you love it's an exciting set of
discoveries in exciting field isn't it
we may now have one of our new Nobel
laureates with us on the phone line
professor Perry huh are you there yeah
yeah I'm here
great thanks for being with us again
this is John Hanson who called you do
you hear me I hear you loud and clear
can you hear me yeah good so I'm the guy
who called you about an hour ago and
now I'm to give you the good news but
now I'm sitting in the session all of
the Academy and we have journalists from
all over the world here and they are of
course eager to ask you questions so why
are you ready to take some questions oh
great God why do who would like to start
- muffled hey no fast as always
congratulations professor I'd like you
to tell us two things actually
first what did you say when you heard
the message today and then what did you
say when you saw your first functioning
molecular machine several years ago I
guess now what I said when I well what I
said when I got this message that I said
I'm um I don't know what to say and I'm
a bit shocked you know because it was
such a great surprise and then my second
remark was I'm so honored and I'm also
emotional about it second your second
what I said when we started machine
working for the first time this was also
a shock because for the first time we
saw a really movement of things you know
and we saw that there was a kind of the
motor-pod function so I was I could
hardly believe that it worked yes thank
you thank you
who's next lady over there you get the
microphone I'm making her Orin from TV
for congratulations on the price thank
you and if you can imagine what your
cars and elevators can be made for Crete
for instance the transporting medical to
active sites where they do the most
where they do what they are meant for
yeah absolutely right and it's a bit
early days of course but once you are
able to control movement you have a
motor you can think of all kinds of
functions so indeed
we think of transporters like in your
body there are many motors and machines
that make it possible that yourself
divided that your muscles work that that
is transport in themselves etc but you
can think also which broader think about
nano machines microrobots think about
tiny robots that you the doctor in the
future will inject in your blood things
and then go to search for a cancer cell
or are going to deliver a drug for
instance with also smart materials for
instance materials that can adapt change
depending of an external signal just
like our body functions that is the kind
of functions you can think of great
fascinating isn't it sky's the limit who
would like to continue more questions
they seem overwhelmed here by all the
possibilities that open up with machines
go ahead yeah now first of all that
muche I feel a little bit like the
Wright brothers huh we were flying a
hundred years ago for the first time and
then people were saying you know why do
we need a flying machine and now we have
a Boeing 747 and Eva's so that is a bit
how I feel but yes the opportunities are
great because if you think what kind of
materials we can make these days with
the camera chemistry and when you are
able to introduce dynamic functions and
built machines or build materials that
can change function there is endless
opportunity so we will build smart
materials in the future that is a big
opportunity materials that will
reconfigure rate that will change that
they'll adapt themselves that they'll
have properties that can change because
we pick up a signal you can think of
nanos
energy converters to make tiny machines
that can store energy and can use that
energy and indeed it opens up a whole
new field of nano machines thank you yes
congratulations professor to the Nobel
price and you were fine achievements in
the field thank you very much
last year one of the laureates in
chemistry told us that he would spend a
good amount of money on wine what are
your plans for spending the money that
you've won today I was wondering how
we're gonna celebrate this fine
achievement and what are you gonna spend
your money on yeah we are of course
celebrating is with our team of all the
talented young students and postdocs
that have been working for all those
years on this program so I want to give
all the credit to the co-workers and all
the people in my team which was
fantastic and it would have been
possible so we certainly will celebrate
with them and we are of course this is
the start of a new period where we are
really going to to try to use these tiny
machines for all kinds of new
applications and so thank you please
question professor congratulations on
your prize David keator from the
Association thank you so much
now obviously the 19th century discovers
a 19th century yielded the aeroplane
lots of beautiful innovations but also
some very deadly ones this could also
lead potentially would you imagine -
well I'll put it another way
what are your worst nightmares with this
discovery what do you fear from your
discovery now I don't know if I have
really nightmares the nice thing is
about that we can design all these
synthetic motors and machines and so
that we can induce all kinds of
autonomous functions so so far when we
build a material a gamma core whatever
you know they are there but they don't
have any dynamic functions and also
normal function in the future
all kinds of material that they'll have
autonomic functions he was like a
bacteria also in the future sir you just
like a cell in your body or a bacterial
cell or so and I think we have to think
about how we can handle these things
safely but I'm not so worried about that
because once we are able to design this
tiny of micro machines and and these
nano robots we will also have the
opportunity to build in all kinds of
safety devices if that is needed and so
for the time being I think we reuse
these materials and so every three
demands as any chemical you know with
with with any tear if we would fall into
you this time here motors and so in a
biological context they have to go to a
failure a careful evaluation with
respect to toxicity and all these things
so we are aware of intent right yes the
lady over there do your professor hi my
name is Oscar and I work in the Nobel
Peace iam and get this fast we say in
Swedish congratulations thank you so
much how come when did you first start
to think about that I would like to make
research about molecular machines how
did you come up with idea yeah yeah
that's a very interesting point we
started when I was in my early days of
my career I started building switches
just like phrases thought out and
champion survives so we could you know a
switch you switch between zero and one
just like in your in a light switch and
the whole idea was to do have an
alternative for information storage and
we wanted to use right and to switch
between two escapes in the molecule and
then certainly we discovered there
besides switching we could also make a
movement that continued in one direction
and that was the start of our rotary
motors and once you I built a rotary
motor then you know you can control
motion at the nano scale because our
motors are only one nanometer one
billionth of a meter in size and so once
you can control motion you can think
about all kinds of dynamic functions
like bull
weren't like transporters like tiny
machinery so it started all which
switches the simple idea the arrow once
which simple ideas are the best ones so
I think that was the last question so
thank you thank you very much professor
fahringer for being with us at the press
conference and I hope to see you here in
December again thank you so much bye bye
for now
thank you are there any questions to the
panel before we close we seem to be
running out of time but if there are any
quick questions to the panelists if not
we'll close this first part of the press
conference I know that several of you
have requested interviews with experts
from Nobel Committee and they will
continue shortly so thank you very much
for your interest and in the Nobel Prize
thanks bye
sorrel snow guru clean sir
you charge the Nobel Committee for
chemistry and have just announced
another price of this year which is
about the tiny molecular machines how
small only yes very very small they're
so small you can't see them you can't
see them by eye you can't even see them
by a light microscope so they are on the
nanometer so one to ten nominator large
and ananna meter if you take a
millimeter and divide it in 1 million
parts each part is an automated 1
million part for the first row there
were 10 1 to 10 thousand times smaller
than the human hair yes you mentioned
also that the dream is always to
construct such tiny machines that's a
very good question because I think that
dream started in the end of the 1950s we
find - lectures where he gave a
challenge to the scientists to construct
molecules that could act as machines and
there are two obstacles one obstacle is
the thing that you need to have parts
that are freely movable either
physically movable or you need some kind
of ISO Mies I summarized herbal bonds
that's one challenge and the other
challenge is that molecular systems
always want to reach equilibrium and
fluctuate around it and they do have all
the random motions so it's a main
challenge to create motion in one
defined direction so when you put in
energy you want your system to either
rotate or move in the direction you have
decided they're not randomly
want to have them silent in equilibrium
but they also wanted to stop the
movement the brown Brownian movement
yeah or at least overcome it because you
can't really stop it it's there too but
you have to come around it one way they
found to come around it was to use a
symmetric molecules so that when you
waste or energy they come in a
frustrated or ten state and when they
relax they will be more prone to relax
in one direction compared to the other
because of their asymmetry and once they
have relaxed they can't get back how
come they move they move because we give
them energy so they are not autonomous
they are moved at will from the user so
we put in a light source we put in heat
or we put in chemical energy so they are
like the man-made motors you have to put
in some kind of fuel plants for example
they also live by light living more I
don't think that this type of event will
eat in living Wally bee been living me
the something can also replicate itself
and there is nothing in those molecules
machines and molecules that there is
also a lot of science fiction about that
and then the nano robots are the main
heroes of science fiction stories and
also they pose a threat when they start
to self-replicate themself so what do
you think about those machines are they
we promise or a big threat I think
they're mainly a big promise because
they don't have this problem with your
cell replication so they cannot really
take over and they are all controlled by
an energy input so if you don't want
them to do something you can just stop
the energy input they will stop working
with us here so what is the next thing
what what is really the dream and the
vision now I think this very nicely when
we called him that this is the start of
a new molecular era so we think this is
a very right time to award this event
price because this is when it takes off
towards the applications and we can only
guess but smart materials for sure will
come material that can change shape or
functional properties when you for
example shine light on them we mentioned
also something that also Richard Feynman
mentioned before it was about minuscule
machines that can bring the medicines to
the body to swallow a doctor
this is also a perspective and one of
our laureates been through Inga has done
some work in that direction with
antibiotics that a photo switchable so
you can activate it yes in the place
where you need the activity and then you
can actually activate them from outside
there are three laureates was it a race
a big competition first so I think
siwash was the first one making the
interlocked rings and developing the
synthesis how to make with good yield
because I think these kind of molecules
could be made before but the heel was
very poor because they mostly itself
when you got most of those and so you
have to play tricks to get high deal or
the interlocked structures there's
really nothing wrong because you can see
it's twice here but it takes two to
tango and the Machine needs more than
one part you can't make a machine of one
part you have to have at least two one
and here are two Dead was but together
they come alive who operated they seem
to be good friends all of them and they
have also worked together on some
projects so they are more much more
co-operators
in the number price motivation was from
1999 so it's almost became to go yes
what happened after them a lot of groups
around the world have taken up this fake
in civilian exploding field in chemistry
so there was enormous enough but they
were paste what the lawyers have done
which is a fantastic achievement I mean
means that it's solid very good solid
methods that others can repeat in other
labs and then they have continued to be
on to this and one development is this
materials that as you change shape when
you shine on them they are still active
yes thank you thank you very much